is it unnecessary for me no I don't
think so although I would like to make a
distinction could I travel without it
yeah absolutely
let's do one more question here from
YouTube this one is from Tom I heard jfm
say he never travels without a grounding
mat isn't that a bit unnecessary oh
let's talk about this so that is true I
always travel with a grounding mat that
I put on the bed I sleep grounded every
night from earthing.com not a sponsor
we've had Clint Ober on the podcast and
earthing or grounding has really helped
me with my inflammation I have a really
bad autoimmune disease and it has helped
tremendously and so is it unnecessary
for me no I don't think so although I
would like to make a distinction could I
travel without it yeah absolutely
and so is it non-essential maybe
technically but it adds value and so
there are sort of three categories that
all of our stuff fits in we have
something called the minimalist rule
book it's 16 rules for living with less
folks can download it for free over on
our website theminimalists.com and one
of those rules is the No Junk Rule and
this applies to my home it also applies
to travel everything I own can fit in
one of three piles it's either essential
truly need it it's not essential but
value-adding or it's junk
the key for me is to not travel with
junk when I used to travel with a um a
hair dryer that was not junk for me it
was non-essential but it added value now
I usually stay at hotel so they have one
so I don't pack it but if light or TK
traveled with a hair dryer it's going to
be junk for them it's just simply going
to get in the way there are some things
I would travel with that I'd love to
travel with but they aren't practical I
get an ice bath every morning and I've
been doing this for about a decade now
and I really enjoy doing that I can't
pack an ice bath with me and that's okay
so I go without it's just not practical
I would also pack my own food if I could
but that's not practical either because
I don't I don't eat any processed foods
so keeping Fresh Foods on long trips
doesn't work and so I'm unable to pack
those things but what I will say is that
there are like yeah three or seven
things in fact I was looking at your
book light and I want to talk to you
about some of these things there are
three things I always travel with one is
a grounding mat one is a sleep mask
wherever I am because I can sleep during
the day I can sleep if I'm on a bus I
can sleep you know if there's a sunlight
just coming through the window or
Moonlight coming through the window or
EMF somewhere and then earplugs just a
basic pair of your plugs that help me
sleep without interruption I'll put a
link to the ones that I use in the show
notes but light in your book on page 69
there are seven items you have but
before we get there you also travel with
a meditation shawl and I know for me
that would be uh unnecessary item for a
few reasons one I believe yours is wool
I read I'm hyper allergic to wool and so
that'd be awful right I'm allergic to
codeine as well it'd be like if I rub
codeine all over me and end up with
rashes that's a huge problem right but
you have a meditation show that you
always travel with and it is a
multi-purpose side maybe talk a bit
about that and then I want to dive into
these seven different items that you
have in your travel bag sure so I've
been a long-term meditation teacher and
practitioner I've been meditating for
like over 20 years at this point and my
shawl I first started using shawls when
I went to India and I I meditated in
India and for those of you who've been
to India before you know that India has
lots of flies there's lots of monkeys
lots of a lot of things but so the
meditation shawl is a way of just
maintaining a temperature control
so making sure that you feel cozy
because the Cozier you are usually the
deeper you can go in meditation and who
doesn't want to go deeper in meditation
it's also a mosquito or fly repellent
because things can't really land on you
and bother you during your meditation
and then I use it also as an eye mask so
when I'm on a plane I'll just tie it
around my head it can also serve as a
pillow so the knot that I tie behind my
head becomes like a little pillow oh wow
on the flight and or on the bus
and yeah there's a talk about in the
book there are multiple purposes for
that and that's one of the things that I
try to that's one of my personal codes
for the things that I carry is how many
purposes can I use this this thing for
and then I'll carry it so for instance I
always travel with a
um a journal and this is just like a
little paper Journal that I can write
anything with I can I can learn
languages I can write down names of
people whose names are very hard to
pronounce and I can write out a little
map for people so and it could flirt you
know if I if I see someone who I find
attractive I can write a little note and
put my number in it and I talk about all
that in the book as well so you know
it's just a way otherwise I've this
would also go into a non-essential
category but it has so many purposes
that
um that it's it's something that I don't
mind carrying around and I and I I
suggest that
we all find our versions of that you
don't need a meditation shawl you don't
need a grounding mat you don't need a
journal but you may have something that
allows you to be more present and that's
what the through line is on all of my
all of my points in the book is that you
know it helps you to become more present
and sleeping if you can do any little
thing that helps you get better sleep
you're going to be a better version of
yourself the next day and what's cool
about that is it's not prescriptive in
the sense that everyone should now
travel with a meditation show and a
grounding mat and earplugs an extra
sleep mask and a journal because the
truth is and I think what you're saying
here is like it really augments your
travel but if I carried it with me and I
didn't use it then it would just weigh
me down a little bit right and so you
had seven items here in the book that I
just wanted to go through a few of these
you talk about what's in my bag my
accessories so you've got a good pin
yeah in fact later in the episode
Professor Sean we're gonna do a tour of
his he's a pin collector he has
extravagant really expensive pins what's
the most expensive one eighty five
thousand dollars it's five five hundred
oh my gosh oh I just got that we'll
we'll do uh yeah we're gonna do a pin
tour with him but you say you travel
with a pin that makes sense especially
with the notebook uh about the beads
that you travel with talk about that so
I usually wear a string of Mala beads
and I I do these I facilitate these
workshops and trainings around the world
it's one of the ways that I make money
and also help to give back and so
because I'm living from a backpack I
don't have a whole wardrobe of you know
robes and suits and things like that I
usually just have a T-shirt and some
genos and so if I'm just walking around
the t-shirt and chinos I'm just a guy
with t-shirt and chinos but if I put
some Mala beads on now I'm a meditation
teacher with t-shirt and chinos and it
just it does a really great job of
accentuating whatever it is that I
happen to be wearing at the time yeah
you're signaling but I I assume there's
a practical aspect to that as well it's
really just decorative honestly okay
yeah yeah and what about you so you
travel the smart watch and a smartphone
so for me a smart watch would totally
get in my way but I'm not now
prescribing well that's silly I can't
believe he travels with a smart watch
how dare you right yeah but it sounds
like you get some value from it yeah so
I actually I had one I don't have it
right now because it broke I don't know
dropped it and it happened yeah he was
still here on time I was still here on
time but what the smart watch did for me
was I'm a big Walker and I like to get
at least ten thousand twelve thousand
steps a day and so the smart watch was
just a way of just seeing okay I've got
this many steps I've got this many more
steps that I want to get throughout the
day okay so instead of driving to that
errand I'm going to walk that errand
yeah and obviously you can do this from
your phone as well pull out your phone
that's what I've been doing but it was
just a little bit more efficient to use
the smart watch for that purpose I do
something similar with the the aura ring
so I think about traveling with it but
it's on my person right uh smartphone
you have listed in here but then also
headphones a tablet and a backup charger
maybe talk about a few of those things
so headphones a lot of times I'll be
walking around so I'm I'm spending most
of my time now in Mexico City
and um and it's a very much a walking
culture and I've been there off and on
for a couple of years and so I've made
friends with people and acquaintances
with people and it's not unusual to be
walking around and run into someone that
you have become acquainted with every
you know 20 minutes
and so but if you have hair air
earphones in a lot of times people won't
stop to talk to you they'll go
it's a signal yeah and then if you don't
feel like talking to that person I'll
just keep in my ear sometimes if you
don't feel like talking to that person
you go yeah
and you keep going and if you do you
take them out and you talk and that's
just one you know another way obviously
you can listen to things podcasts and
books and Etc through your headphones
but it's a good way to of kind of
editing how you're investing your time
as you're out and about walking around
and because this it's a way to let
people say face and then you get to also
manage your time a little bit better
because it's not really like a personal
thing like I don't like this person it's
just that I may not have time to stop
and have this conversation right now and
you might not have the attention or the
resources right now and so it's gonna
feel like you're blowing them off even
though that's not your intention right
by the way Kobe used to do that he wrote
about that in Mamba mentality in the
locker room he'd have his headphones on
because he wanted to meditate before the
game and that kept people from talking
but is that why you listen a lot of
audiobooks so that you don't have to
carry books around yeah I can't I don't
have any space for books so I do
audiobooks for sure yeah now in your bag
in the book you talk about you have
about 30 items that you keep in your day
day pack you have a button-down shirt a
pair of pants two pairs of shorts three
pairs of underwear three shirts a jacket
a hoodie a sweatshirt a belt a pair of
casual sneakers another pair of shoes a
pair of sandals toiletries refillable
water bottle meditation shawl meditation
teaching kit tripod podcast microphone
rechargeable battery tablet journal and
the mall of beads now has any of this
list changed since you published the
book
um no not really it's all kind of the
same I because again I've been traveling
like that for five years so you can kind
of see okay what are the essentials most
of mine I would say are Essentials in
the essential category right except for
the meditation shawl but considering
what I do for work it's kind of an
essential thing
um and every now and again there may be
a sweatshirt that changes out or I'll
acquire a new sort of windbreaker I just
got a windbreaker in fact the other day
because I'm going to be on the road for
about a month and a half and
although it's supposed to be warm
everywhere I'm going you just never know
and I happen to be in a retail store and
I saw this really thin windbreaker which
I could actually wore on the plane here
which came in perfectly
um and it balls up really nicely in my
back so you know I'll make little
exceptions here and there I don't know
how long I'll keep it it wasn't the
quality wasn't like it's not like it's
not exactly you know high-end or
anything like that but I'm definitely
open to
um getting rid of things or sometimes
like I said the watch broke I haven't
replaced it I'm not sure I'm going to
replace it anytime soon because I really
had an affinity for that particular
watch so yeah it just depends but that's
generally a good representation of what
you'll find on me if you happen to catch
me like traveling somewhere on an
airport yeah so so you're traveling
lightly with these things but it also
helps you travel lightly emotionally
mentally spiritually as well you're not
being burdened by material access you
know people ask me like when did you
start to become a minimalist and
normally they are expecting me to say
which date and five years ago I started
which was May 31st of 2018 but I credit
when I started taking my meditation
practice seriously as the moment I
became a minimalist because it allowed
me to not hold on to things so much and
again a lot of the things that we have
now or especially if you feel like we
have too much stuff usually
if we trace the steps back there's some
emotional thing that made us feel like
we needed to have all of this stuff and
um and if we can create a more
spaciousness inside we may find that you
still keep it but it's easier to let it
go especially if it gets taken from you
you know if someone steals it or you
lose it and you find yeah you know I
actually am okay without it and a lot of
times that's what has to happen we have
to we have to be separated from it you
know the airline loses it or something
like that and we have to exist for five
days without it and you see actually
it's not I didn't really need it as much
as I thought I needed it so you
mentioned you know your kids having
these items that they absolutely need
but as adults we all kind of have this
sort of childlike sense of attachment
yes to certain things and you don't
really need it I would say the opposite
also with children often manifest when
they are present and they're playing I
can't tell how many times my daughter
has lost her shoes they just leaves them
at a park they should never lose that
stick or that ball or something like
that and so when she's in the moment
she's not thinking about oh I need to go
back and get those shoes or whatever it
might be it's that state of
non-attachment that she's actually
living in she doesn't have to practice
it as a 10 year old it just tends to
happen regularly you know somewhere
around puberty we we begin to then
detach from our parents and we start to
attach to these other things within
culture whether it's material
possessions or relationships or
ideologies or dogmas or whatever it
might be and we're essentially trading
one healthy attachment to the parents to
a attachment that really Keeps Us stuck
and prevents us from going quite often
where we want to go hey I hope you
enjoyed that quick highlight from the
minimalist private podcast if you'd like
to go deep with the private podcast head
on over to patreon just click the link
in the description it keeps our podcast
and our YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free if you're not ready
for it don't worry you can just check
out this video right here
foreign
[Music]